[Music]
[Laughter]
like let's talk
[Music]
Oh
Cave yourself could to my cage me I'm
engaged and then you try your best to
keep yeah like your chin like not open
your mouth at all in general okay
and what's very good okay is it we're
gonna tell me welcome to Tony wrote this
all while wrote the lyric that he is
also cage and I do the voice here it's
pretty awesome to be here
America thumbs to welcome Jim alright
ready Jim or can't yeah we're going to
do the yeah I be honest also you have
the lead in but yeah great oh my god
it ripped the math like so blend vendor
yeah we works yeah okay uh what should
we do one more sure well maybe because
the further closed up it'll be the math
you know Logan see I got an awesome
anthem is there anything like all right
I'll do this a to see in this one yeah
okay okay ready
you're beginning yeah okay
[Music]
all right and chop chop chop chop chop
good we'll do one more on the chopping
rosettes just a hint slower yeah right
and chop chop job job job job job great
yeah I hear camera keep your picture of
both of us having the
k-pax but all my rage I'm soldiers
Nikhil okay oh my god they're brothers
oh my god it's so good are you agree
thank you yes goddammit oh so you did
have a access to guard oh yeah my
friends like used to have it she says
yeah it's a new pile to get you the
first oh wow yeah good thing you connect
that was a great time thank you
no it's a black widow scar doing that's
what I wish I had your time yeah it
really does yeah I'm just happy to be
here so again like glad yeah that's
right okay okay I guess happy you know
but we are going to choose the intro to
uh it's just a back to the pad oh the
beginning really probably sent don't
have two of these chance to if you were
gonna give them back with Malcolm
yeah true we've always had a chance to
the future yeah it's really close to
make sense to work
Charlie yeah personal face yeah well you
really did cut your hair oh yeah that
wasn't a CG effects yeah
Rob really cut my hair honest no genius
how dare you rob how dare I
how dare you hello hi there everyone we
are back with a behind the scene we are
in business
yes no this one yeah maybe that's a
little ratty though you know if I keep
pretty ratty in the film again let's see
I'm supposed to be where is her oh yeah
that's right he does look pretty ready
yeah I can't afford any wigs like this
hey why do all these pictures I bought
to me Island back now I like what I'm
forgetting looks pretty good just like
Jesus Jesus yeah critic are your peers
per hour to wait a little
okay sorry thing and we did just a hint
of a pause here polls happen again yeah
good SK like Bugs Bunny
let me a poll there's a hand off camera
oh we go ahead yeah okay all right well
we'll just take it from Lebow like this
ax okay yep wait a whole leg up hold in
my graduate boy okay my good I couldn't
see it I hit more days later yeah all
right procore line go ahead Lisette
action where Paul Lolo Leopold quite on
the side okay try get ready action
wait a whole little air hole good
getting very close to like special Jack
what makes my movie sweeter together ah
look at those all right for that I think
we had like couple more shots after hey
okay Robert competitive up now men you
direct the actors not for people behind
the camp oh yeah everybody over I bet
you weren't directing this is not in the
CIA we're living this is in the scene
yeah oh are you employee Walters that
bad of an activity just couldn't tell
them to look at the edge of this license
no like physically you know why would
you either why would you say to the left
as like and I'm sorry Walter I didn't do
a live ah okay okay so yeah it's only
you're lying on this over anywhere from
faces okay more nasal
yeah know what I mean what a crazy yeah
yeah yeah no I am II what you broke in
this how you been
yes the more days across How to Train
Your Dragon is this grip this is real
boy yeah yeah let's see can we keep it
cannot see I'm not gonna change it on
each side boy
I clearly can't see one more reason
though I don't read the script script
reads yeah bad for ya you can just be
like that just do that slow hold up a
good okay decide okay ready and action
[Music]
you don't really show just a nominee
system I'll go ahead and take a step
closer in Pesaro version of urban
boarding yeah Mauri Mauri Mauri guys
think when I step over here the
adventure speech okay alright
what you're going to do is that you're
going to the faces when you begin to
turn back like this or do you want the
hatch you know let's not be the big star
you right I'll go ahead couples is the
camera yeah I think yeah that'll work
you look that way in the turn
that's work arms holy earth yeah ready
and okay not
great let's write a little more just a
slow return this time ready and X
great okay I think that's it for home it
occurred to me we should have at some
point referred to Cajun marichal and
Rick and Morty Nick and Lori hey Nick
embarrass on your head name haha
my whole life I wanted to head back yes
but now I can write Oh
bring that back yeah just like yeah
that's about picking up that fat little
very first thing yes Debbie burger
yeah I thought that was Jerry I don't
know how much bone meal I know it's like
yeah I was gonna say if we going on the
head
Skaar chose editing so what are we gonna
do to meet my music Cinematic Universe a
cue the whale ha ha ha people yeah all
right oh I do uh do one this is for the
lineup so yeah I do like uh yeah the
bear without any Freddie okay yes number
doesn't matter I'm clearly wearing jeans
and sneakers I pick Jack like okay yeah
you okay ready
in today's environment departmental in
Berlin he fishes in Jack we right back
knowledge is power for real okay so that
it for me and this garbage I think so
alright yeah look at the letter e sure
yeah I need double check Janice and the
guitar
yes mm-hmm they call me Bacchus D just
believe is also hahaha
yes good this black is deep
oh my okay
yes you are right righto yeah you know
what that scare you seem cowboy yes
there his girlfriend
yeah like when she was walking up I'm
like who's day oh no no it as fine as
the keying might be an issue bigger I
want a real fellow
my view cream true
oh you have calendar sorry we can maybe
better siblings good Oh have you guys
seen kidnapped by the way speaking of
Marco
I heard of a head I've heard of how
amazing it
it's enjoyably bad like that like what I
yeah it's like cool like it's taken but
with an actual parents over here is I
could be a little bit i gala a little
bit dated your picture sorry
great yeah what how did you Justin
Bieber um so we need you at Jim welcome
by already you know I'm Bette Midler we
are you have a thing yeah it is any kind
of top IB it's just a normal
I'm sure like a blouse or something yeah
so Jim is next is Jared Leto as to
Cherbourg the churn evocative oh yeah
which everyone's always like no except
the devil it's Chernabog I'm like I
would totally believe that not as
beginning of the thing
they're like yeah we want us to be Satan
celebrating with hell and I'm like okay
I'll go down you call by the way you
make a movie about him you know since I
got the devil oh my god that's all
called honest about well you know the
wizard in Fantasia his name it's not in
the movie but a name is yen Sid because
it's just me to go backward yeah kind of
cool
oh yeah I think you know we were saying
about the short Sorcerer's Apprentice
the cartoon it's so weird because
there's like one of the most dark
mysterious atmospheric shadow heavy
gothic I like I've ever done but the
story's not the least bit dark
whatsoever it is like the lightest story
you can put all that heavy atmosphere in
which is just so fascinating yeah just
it's mystifying is coming to life yeah
it's great
yeah it's a janitor moving up as I'm
just gonna make this like huge epic dark
and mysterious it's like claw X it works
it works so well yeah yeah no watching
it again guys even you're watching again
I'm like yep this is really - yes I
would kind of lose it with the rest of
Fantasia because I get sucked into like
NIDA bull mountain memory and stuff but
it's like watching that again like yeah
this this is really really good yeah I
love it
yeah so what is this oh oh you've got oh
my god yeah here here what this way yeah
oh just have your weakness it should
just hit on man is the fella got to you
yeah that stinks right what of it yeah
oh yeah
okay Phil Joe shut up yes okay all right
razor there
shut up soon a cup recalled in charge of
google word okay you got a little bit
jump damn is fire don't you to catch on
fire
[Laughter]
[Applause]
excellence we have on your signature
character yeah shitty look slightly off
camera
ah baby I'm here at the yeah
yes it's right one more with that what I
long okay okay stroking scheming fire
kiss Jessica
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh okay this is going yeah with like Sam
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah I just saw a great running joke
everyone's a while I'm sure I get my
shots on where we did some whicker's
just after Jill where we just look over
and she's which is just over there yeah
don't be hard to get a couple shots in
here well no no because we've done a
couple of shots of us just looking at or
I leave me looking at her while wait oh
he's looking forward like enough no it's
just um Sarah nobody plays i copilot oh
thank you oh man just go meet your own
good yeah yeah there okay everybody in a
shot everyone make sure yeah everyone
looks good Corey just take a baby step
back there I got bad yeah maybe you can
be mozzie okay just don't know my two I
guess okay all right already
okay yeah yeah okay ready and
action we did it he said nothing that's
a shame
please to try oh well hmm I guess we'll
go on to without him all right one more
mm yeah all right try to find those same
spots you got a girl
what no I was so plugging it soon as he
hit well I'm like I want to it so you're
gonna pay good good I was just holding
holding back to smile a stoic oops talk
it's just okay okay I know everyone
that's your right nailed it that it
never end up yes all right
ready and action
weird he said no oh that's a shame wait
to try it
oh well hmm I guess we're going to or
without them good fellas better yeah
action damn it you guys
hey jerk with the camera hey double
boner you play one on two yeah it's
super easy I know right he is so stupid
[Laughter]
there was horrific
wonderful exactly I only get like two
hops and then I want the rest of the way
to that show on camera Oh hopefully the
camera was eaten and so was Malcolm yes
it's gone just leaves behind a shoe good
okay yes Terry you were done with that
rewards catabolism let's see all right
we have
[Music]